The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So John is going to
present project three, beta.
JOHN: All right.
So here's the performance
grades.
In general, the submission went
a lot better than last
time in that things were on
time and nobody failed to
build, or forgot to add files
to their project, or so on.
We did change the scoring
mechanism a little bit.
In the [? mdriver ?]
that we gave you, if your
validator failed you on any of
your traces, your
score is a zero.
In this one, we decided
to be nicer.
We replaced your validator with
our correct validator.
And for traces that you failed,
you get a zero for the
points that those traces
contribute.
But you did get an overall
partial score, even if you
failed a couple traces.
So on that note, the reference
implementation does get a 56
on this score.
And there were people who had
slower than reference
implementations that
landed below 56.
So that might be something to
think about for your final
submission.
The high score was a 96.
And there were actually quite
a few groups in the 90s.
So overall, people did
really well on this.
With that said, your validators
didn't really--
I guess they were OK.
But there's some people whose
validators failed projects
that were correct, and other
people whose validators failed
to detect certain situations.
So that's also something to
work on for the final.
We won't be releasing the
stock validators.
So it'll be up to you guys to
find out what's wrong with
your validators and fix them.
And along the same lines of
correctness, once again, for
the final submission,
we'll be running--
actually even for the beta,
I believe, we're going to
Valgrind your projects and
look for memory errors.
So do that to your own projects
and investigate any
messages you get.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JOHN: OK.
So the highlighted column
number 31 refers to the
reference implementation
of the validator.
So that's the authority.
If that's green, then your
implementation is correct.
And so hopefully, a correct
validator would
agree with column 31.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JOHN: Yes.
question.
How can it be that most of--
so an implementation is
vertical, so tests are
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
JOHN: No.
The implementations are
horizontal, and
the tests are vertical.
AUDIENCE: So we want our column
to look like column 31?
Or we want--
JOHN: You want-- your validators
correctness score
will be determined by whether
or not your column number
corresponds with column 31.
And then, your implementations
correctness will purely be
determined by whether 31 marks
your row red or green.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE]
columns that are all green,
our validators are not
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
Is that what you're saying?
PROFESSOR: That's right.
JOHN: That's correct.
PROFESSOR: Whereas the rows that
are green, that's what we
like to see.
We like green rows.
And then, we like columns
that match column 31.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE].
The first row should
be all red.
And right now, [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN: Right.
PROFESSOR: That's correct.
JOHN: Whatever error this
person had, very few
validators seems to
have caught them.
Which is very surprising,
because what we did for your
validator.c is that we removed
the line of code that it
contained, and we added the
comment that explained in
English exactly what that
line of code did.
So it was kind of interesting to
see that not everybody came
up with the validator that's
identical to reference one.
PROFESSOR: OK--
JOHN:JOHN: Yeah.
So please run Valgrind on your
code before the final
submission.
And we'll be posting your
personalized results to your
repose sometime probably by
the end of the day, either
today or tomorrow.
PROFESSOR: Great.
All right, you can take
this [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Or you can [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Here you go.
You guys can have it here, in
case you need to chip in.
OK.
So today, we're going to talk
about programming in parallel.
Parallel programming
and so forth.
So this is I'm sure what you've
all been waiting for.
Oops.
Oh, we have no power here.
There we go.
Now I've got power.
OK.
Let's see here.
How's that?
Good.
OK.
So we talk about multicore
programming.
And let me start with a
little bit of history.
So since the mid
to late 1960s--
so how many years is that?
50 years.
Wow.
Semiconductor density
has been increasing
at the rate of about--
it's been doubling about
every 18 to 24 months.
OK.
So every year, every one to two
years, every year and a
half to two years, we
get a doubling of
density on the chips.
And that's a trend that
still is continuing.
OK.
So that's called Moore's law,
the doubling of density of
integrated circuits.
And so, this is basically a
curve showing how transistor
count is rising.
OK.
So all these green things are
Intel CPUs and what the
transistor count is on them.
Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE]
the lines in [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: So there have
been some technology
changes along the way.
So in particular, the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] transition is
back down here I think.
I don't remember which
one that is.
Well, this is actually
a different one.
What we're looking at right now
is the transistors, which
have been very smooth.
OK.
So I'll explain this
curve in a minute.
So there's two things
plotted on here.
One is the Intel CPU density,
and the other is what the
clock speed of those
processes is.
And so these are the clock
speed numbers.
And so, the integrated circuit
technology has been--
the density has been doubling.
And it's really an unbelievable
sort of social
and economic process, that
this has basically
been called a law.
Because what happens is if a--
there's so many people that
contribute to making
integrated circuits be dense.
There's so many pieces of
technology that go into that.
And what happens is if you
decide that you're going to
try to jump and try to make
something that goes faster
than Moore's law, what happens
is it's more expensive
for you to do it.
And none of the other
participants in that economy
can keep up.
And you're just going to
be more expensive.
So people will op for the
cheapest thing that gets the
factor of two every
18 to 24 months.
Whereas if you're behind, then
nobody uses your stuff.
So everybody's got this sort
of self-fulfilling prophecy
that the rate at which the
density is increasing has just
been extremely stable
for over 50 years.
It's remarkable.
Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE]
every six months.
And somehow, [INAUDIBLE]
you would have self-replicated?
PROFESSOR: No, I'm
not saying that.
What I'm saying is that there
is some amount of everybody
expecting that this
is the point that
everybody's going to be at.
And so if you try to go more
aggressively than that, you
can get burned because you'll
be more expensive.
If you don't go that fast,
you're going to get burned
because nobody's going to adopt
your particular piece of
the technology.
And so, what happens is
everybody sort of settles for
this regular repeating.
It's a remarkable social and
economic phenomenon.
It's got very little to do at
some level of technology.
It's just that we know that
we can improve things.
But what's amazing is this
growth has gone through many
transitions.
At one point, they said we
aren't going to be able to
build integrated circuits any
more densely because all of
the masks that were made--
it's basically, you make
computers with a photographic
process of exposing and
using masks that
you shine light through.
It's the way they
used to do it.
And what happened was the wave
lengths of light were such
that you were just simply not
going to be able to get the
resolutions.
So what did they do?
They switched to eBeams.
OK.
Electrons rather than photons
to expose the silicon wafers
and so forth.
And so, they've gone through a
whole bunch of transitions and
different technologies.
And yet, throughout all of that,
it's been just a very
steady progress at about the
rate of 18 to 24 months per
doubling of density.
And that is still going on,
and is projected to go on
maybe for 10 years more.
It's going to run out, I
hope in my lifetime.
And certainly within
your lifetimes.
So that has been going.
Then, there's second phenomenon
that has been going
on since about mid-1980s.
And that is that the clock
speed has actually been
growing on a similar curve,
where basically, we've been
getting 30% faster
processors, clock
speed, since the mid-1980s.
But something happened there,
which was in around 2003, it
flattened out.
And the reason is, as a
practical matter, clock speed
for air cooled systems
is bounded at
somewhere around 5 gigahertz.
If you want to liquid cool
it or nitrogen cool it or
something, you could
make it go faster.
But basically, the problem is
that things get too hot.
And they cannot convey
the heat out.
So for a while, if you have
greater density, the
transistors get smaller.
They switch faster.
And you can make the clock
speed go faster.
But at some point, they
hit the wall.
And so there the vendors were.
People like Intel,
AMD, Motorola.
A variety of the semiconductor
manufacturers.
And what's happened is they
can still make integrated
circuits more and more dense.
But they can't clock
them any faster.
OK.
So here's what's going
on in the circuits.
So here's essentially how much
power was being dissipated by
a variety of Intel processors
along the way, and what they
[INAUDIBLE]
2000.
They started getting hot and
hotter, until if they just
continued this trend, they were
going to be trying to
have junction temperatures that
are as hot as the surface
of the sun.
Well, they clearly
couldn't do that.
OK.
So you might say, well, let's
put it off a few years.
Yeah, but how many years are
you going to put this off?
And so, what happened
was they got stuck.
They simply could not make chips
get clocked in faster.
So what did they decide to do?
They got all the silicon area,
but they can't make the
processors faster with it.
So their solution was to scale
performance to put many
processing cores on the
microprocessor chip.
So this is an example
of a Core i7.
It's a four core.
One, two, three, four
cores processor.
We actually have six
core machines now.
But I didn't update
the figure.
And what's going to happen now
is Moore's law is going to
continue for a few more years.
And so it looks like each new
generation of Moore's law is
going to potentially double the
number of cores per chip.
So you folks are using
12 core machines.
Two six core chips.
Well, that's going to basically
keep increasing.
And so, we're going to get more
and more cores per chip.
OK.
That's all well and good.
But it turns out that there's
a major issue.
And that's software.
Everybody has written
their software.
And there's billions and
billions and billions of
dollars invested in existing
legacy software that's written
for how many cores?
One.
And moving it to multicore is a
nightmare for these companies.
OK.
And it's potentially a nightmare
for these vendors.
Because if people say, gee, you
can't make the processors
go any faster, why should
I buy a new processor?
My old processor is as
good as my new one.
OK.
And so, anyway, so that's
sometimes been called the
multicore challenge.
The multicore menace.
The multicore revolution.
Whatever.
But that's what it's
all about.
It's all about the issue of the
frequency scaling of the
clocks, verses, Moore's law.
Which talks about what
the density is.
OK.
So their solution is to do--
and so what we're going to talk
about for a bunch of the
rest of the term is going to
be, how do you actually
program multicore processors?
We're going to look at some
fairly new software technology
for doing that.
So here's an abstract multicore
architecture.
It's not precise.
This is only showing
one level of cache.
So we have processors connected
to a cache.
In fact, of course, you
know that there are
multiple levels of cache.
Yeah, this is the international
symbol for cache
if you live in the US.
So the processors have
their cache.
Of course, you know that what
actually happens is you have
multiple levels of cache.
And it's shared cache
at some levels.
OK.
So it's more complex
than this.
But this is sort of an abstract
way of understanding
a bunch of the issues.
And then, of course, they only
get more complicated as we
look at reality, as with all
these hardware related things.
And so, this is a chip
multiprocessor.
Now there are other ways
of using the silicon.
So another way of using the
silicon is building things
like graphics processors and
using silicon for a very
special purpose thing.
So that instead of saying,
let's build multiple
processors, you can say, let's
dedicate some fraction of the
silicon real estate.
Instead of to general purpose
computing, let's dedicate it
to some specific purpose, like
graphics, or some kind of
stream processing,
or what have you.
Sensor processing.
A variety of other things
you can do.
But one main trend is doing
chip multiprocessors.
So we're going to talk
a little bit about
shared memory hardware.
Just enough to get you folks off
the ground to understand
what's going on underneath
the system.
And then, we're going to talk
about four concurrency
platforms, which are not
the only platforms
one can program in.
But they're ones that you
should be familiar with.
The last one, Cilk++, is the
one we're going to do our
programming assignments in.
And then, race conditions, we're
going to talk about,
because that's the biggest thing
that comes up when you
do parallel programming compared
to ordinary serial
programming.
It's the most pernicious
type of bugs.
And you need to understand race
conditions and need a way
of handling it.
So here's basically--
so we'll start with shared
memory hardware.
So the main thing that shared
memory hardware provides is a
thing called cache coherence.
OK.
And the basic idea is that you
want every processor to be
able to fetch stuff out
of local caches
because that's fast.
But at the same time, you want
them to have a common view of
what is stored in a
given location.
So let's run through this
example and see what the
problem is.
And then, I'll show
you how they solve
it in sketchy detail.
So here's a processor.
Says he wants to load
the value of x.
And in main memory here,
x has got the value of
3, up here in DRAM.
OK.
So x moves through
to the processor,
where it gets consumed.
And it leaves behind the
fact that x equals 3
in its local cache.
Well, now along comes the
second processor.
It says, I want x too.
And perhaps the same
thing happens.
Very good.
So far, no problem.
So two caches may have
the same value of x.
They may both want to
use x, and it's both
in their local caches.
Now comes along the
third processor.
Says load x as well.
Well, it turns out that
it's actually--
what I showed you on
the second case is
not the common case.
If these two processors, these
two processing cores, are on
the same chip, it's generally
cheaper for this guy to fetch
it out of one of these guys
caches than it is to fetch it
out of DRAM.
DRAM is slow.
Getting it locally
is much cheaper.
So basically, in this case, he
gets it from this processor.
The first processor.
All is well and good.
They're all sharing
merrily around.
OK.
And then this fella decides
if he wants
to load it, no problem.
He can just load it.
He loads it locally.
No problem.
OK.
This guy decides, oh,
he's going to store
some value to x.
In this case, he's going
to store the value 5.
So he sets x equal to 5.
OK.
fine.
OK, now what?
Now this guy says,
let me load x.
He gets the value x equals 3.
Uh-oh.
If your parallel program
expected that this guy had
gone first and it set x value
x equal to 5, these guys are
now incorrect.
And so, the idea of cache
coherence is not letting this
happen, making it so that
whenever a value is changed by
a processor, the other
processors see that change and
yet, they're still able most
of the time to execute
effectively out of their
own local caches.
OK.
So that's the problem.
So do people understand
basically what the cache
coherence problem is?
Yes, question?
AUDIENCE: If the last processor
was to store x and
set x equals 5, as soon as that
happens, wouldn't that
write DRAM x equals 5?
PROFESSOR: Good.
So there's actually two
types of strategies
that are used in caches.
One is called write through.
And one is called write back.
What you're describing
is write through.
What right through caches do
is if you write a value, it
pushes it all the
way out to DRAM.
These days, nobody uses
write through.
You're always going to DRAM.
You're always exercising the
slow DRAM versus being able to
just write it locally.
But you do have to do something
about these guys
that are going to have
the shared values.
So here's the mechanism
that they use.
So what most people do these
days is write back caches.
Which basically means you only
write it back when you really
need to evict or
what have you.
You don't always write it
all the way through.
And so here's how these
schemes work.
So, right.
So that's a bogus value for
that kind to be getting.
So let's take a look.
So what they use is what's
called-- the simplest is
called an MSI protocol.
There are somewhat more
complicated ones called MESI
protocols, and ones
that are MOESI.
"Mo-esi" and "messy".
Anyway, the MESI one is probably
the one you'll hear
most often.
It's just a little bit more
complicated than this one.
But it saves you one extra
access when we do a write.
I'll explain it in
just a minute.
But let's first understand the
simplest of these mechanisms.
So what you do is in each cache,
you're going to label
each cache line with a state.
And basically, it's because
of these states that you
associate with a cache line that
cache lines end up having
to be long.
OK?
Because if you think about,
you'd like cache lines to be
at some level very short, in
that then you have more
opportunity to have just the
stuff in cache that you want,
from a temporal locality
point of view.
It's one thing if you want to
bring in extra lines, extra
data, for spatial locality.
But to insist that it all be
there whether you access it or
not, that's not clear how
helpful that it is.
However, what instead is we have
things like, on the Intel
architecture, 64 bytes
of cache line.
And the reason is because
they're keeping extra data
with each cache line.
And they want the data to be
the larger fraction of what
they're keeping compared
to the control
information about the data.
So in this case, they're
keeping three values.
Three bits.
The M bit says this cache
block has been modified.
Somebody's written to it.
And what they do is they, in
this protocol, they guarantee
in the protocol that if somebody
has it in the M
state, no other caches contain
this block in either the M
state or S state.
So what are those states?
So the S state is when
other caches may be
sharing this block.
And the I state is that this
cache block is invalid.
It's the same as if
it's not there.
It's empty entry.
So it just marks this entry.
There's no data there.
The cache line that's there is
not really there, is basically
what it says.
So here, you see for example
that this fella has x equals
13 in the modified state.
And so, if you look across here,
oh, nobody else has that
in either the M or
the S state.
They only have it in the
I state or not at all.
If you have it in the shared
state, as these guys have,
well, they all have it in the
shared state and notice the
values are all the same.
And then, if it's in the invalid
state, here this guy
once again has it in the
modified state, which means
these guys don't have it in
either the S or M state.
So that's the invariant.
So what's the basic idea
behind the cache?
The MSI protocol?
The idea is that before you can
write on a location, you
must first invalidate all
the other copies.
So whenever you try to write
on something that's shared
across a bunch of things or
that somebody else has
modified, what happens is over
the network goes out a
protocol to invalidate
all the other copies.
So if they're just being shared,
that's no problem.
Because all you do
is just have them
drop it from the cache.
If it's modified, then it may
have to be written back or the
value brought back to you, so
that you're in a position of
changing it.
If somebody has it modified,
then you don't have it.
So therefore, you need to
bring it in and make the
change to it.
Question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
three states?
PROFESSOR: Three states.
Not three bits.
Two bits.
Right.
OK.
So the idea is you first
invalidate the other copies.
Therefore, when a processor core
is changing the value of
some variable, it has
the only copy.
And by making sure that it only
has the only copy, you
make sure that you never have
copies out there that are
anything except copies of
what everybody else has.
That they're all the same.
OK.
Does everybody follow that?
So there's hardware under
there doing that.
It's actually pretty
clever hardware.
In fact, the verification of
cache protocols is a huge
problem for which there's a lot
of technology built to try
to verify to make sure these
cache protocols work the way
they're supposed to work.
Because what happens in practice
is there are all
these intermediate states.
What happens if this guy starts
doing this while this
guy is doing that, and these
protocols start getting mixed,
and so forth?
And you've got to make
sure that works out.
And that's what's going
on in the hardware.
The MESI protocol does a
simple optimization.
It says, look, before I store
something, I probably
want to read it.
It's likely I'm going
to read it.
So I can read it in two ways.
I can read it in a way that
says that it is--
where it's just going
to be shared.
But if I expect that I'm going
to write it, let me when I
read it instead of getting a
shared copy, let me get an
exclusive copy.
And that's where the
E comes from.
Let me get an exclusive copy.
In other words, go through the
invalidation protocols on the
read, so that with the
expectation that when you
write, you don't have to then
wait for the invalidation to
occur at that point.
So it's a way of reducing the
latency of the protocol by
getting it exclusively by
the read that you do
before you do the write.
So rather than doing a
read, which would go
out and get the value--
but everybody [? has them ?]
shared-- then doing the write,
and then doing a whole
invalidation protocol, if I
basically get it in exclusive
mode on the read, then I go out,
I get the value, and I
invalidate everybody else.
Now I've just saved myself
half the work
and half the latency.
Or basically saved myself
some latency.
Not half the latency.
OK?
So basically, what you should
know is there is invalidation
stuff going on behind when you
start using shared memory,
behind the scenes which
can slow down your
processor from executing.
Because it can't do the things
that it needs to do until it
goes through the protocol.
Any questions about that?
That's basically the level
we're going to cover the
hardware at.
And so, you'll discover that in
doing some your problems,
that if you're not careful,
you're going to create what
are called invalidation storms,
where you have a whole
bunch of things that are red,
and they're distributed across
the processor.
And then you go in, and
you set one value.
And suddenly, vrrrrrruuuum.
Gee, how come that wasn't
a fast store?
The answer is it's going through
and invalidating all
those other copies.
Good.
So let's turn to the
real hard problem.
So it turns out that building
these things is not
particularly well understood.
But it's understood
a lot better than
programming these beasts.
OK.
And so, we're going to focus on
some of the strategies for
programming.
So it turns out that trying to
program their processor cores
directly is painful.
And you're liable to make a lot
of errors, as we'll see.
Because we're going to talk
about races soon.
And so the idea of a current
currency platform is to do
some level of abstraction of the
processor cores to handle
synchronization communication
protocols, and often to do
things like load balancing, so
that the work that you're
doing can be moved across from
processor to processor.
And so, here are some examples
of concurrency platforms.
Pthreads and WinAPI threads,
we're going to talk more in
detail about.
Pthreads is basically for
Unix type systems,
like Linux and such.
WinAPI threads is for Windows.
There's threading building
blocks, TBB, OpenMP, which is
a standard, and Cilk++.
Those are all examples of
concurrency platforms that
make it easier to program
these parallel machines.
So I'm going to do, as an
example, I'm going to use the
Fibonacci numbers, which you
have seen before I'm sure,
because we've actually even
used it in this class.
This is Leonardo da Pisa, who
was also known as Fibonacci.
And he introduced--
he was the most brilliant
mathematician of his day.
He came basically out of the
blue, doing all kinds of
beautiful mathematics very
early in the Renaissance.
You'll recognize 1202 is
very early Renaissance.
But it turns out, for those of
you of Indian descent, the
Indian mathematicians
had already
discovered all this stuff.
But it didn't make it into
Western culture except for
Leonardo da Pisa.
So here's a program as you might
write it in C. So Fib
int n says, well, if n is
less than 2, return n.
So if it's 0 or 1, we return,
Fib of 0 is 0.
Fib of 1 is 1.
And otherwise, we compute Fib of
n minus 1, compute Fib of n
minus 2, and return the sum.
Simple recursive program.
Here's the main routine.
We get the argument from the
command line, compute the
result, and then print
out Fibonacci
of whatever is whatever.
Pretty simple piece of code.
So what we're going to do is
take a look at what happens in
each of these four concurrency
platforms to see how it is
that they make this easy to
run this in parallel.
Now just a disclaimer here.
This is a really bad way--
I hope you all recognize--
of computing Fibonacci
numbers.
So this is exponential
time algorithm.
And you all know the linear
time algorithm, which is
basically computed up
from the bottom.
And some of you probably know
there's a logarithmic time
algorithm based on squaring
matrices.
Two by two matrices.
So in any case, we're all
about performance here.
But obviously, this is a really
poor choice to do
performance on.
But it is a good didactic
example, because it's so the
structure and the issues that
you get into in doing this
with a very simple program that
I can fit on a slide.
OK.
So when you execute Fibonacci,
when you call Fib of 4, it
calls Fib of 3 and Fib of 2.
And Fib of 3 calls Fib
of 2 and Fib of 1.
And Fib of 1 just returns Fib
of 2, calls [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
1, 0, et cetera.
And so basically, you get an
execution trace that basically
corresponds to walk
of this tree.
So if you were doing this in C,
you'd basically call this,
call this, call this.
Get a value return.
Call this.
Add the two values together.
Return here.
Call this.
Add the two values together.
Call the return there.
And so forth.
You walk that using a stack, a
call stack, in the execution.
The key idea for parallelization
is, well, gee.
Fib of n minus 1 and fib of n
minus 2 are really, in this
calculation, completely
independently calculated.
So let's just do them
at the same time.
And they can be executed at
the same time without
interference, because
all they're doing is
basing it on n.
They're not using any shared
memory or anything even for
this particular program.
So let's take a look,
to begin with, how
Pthreads might do this.
So Pthreads is a standard that
ANSI and the IEEE have
established for--
and I actually believe this is
a little bit out of date.
I believe there's now
a 2010 version.
I'm not sure.
But I recall that they were
working on a new version.
But anyway, this is a recent
enough standard.
It's a standard that has been
revised over the years, the
so-called POSIX standard.
So you'll hear, Pthreads is
basically POSIX threads.
It's basically what you might
characterize as a do it
yourself concurrency platform.
It's kind of like assembly
language for parallelism.
It allows you to do the things
you need to do, but you're
sort of doing it all by hand,
one step at a time.
It's built as a library of
functions with special non-C
or C++ semantics.
And we'll look at what some
of those semantics are.
Each thread implements an
abstraction of a processor,
which are multiplexed onto the
machine resources by the
Pthread runtime implementation.
Threads communicate through
shared memory.
And library functions mask
the protocols involved in
interthread coordination.
So you can start up threads, et
cetera, and their library
function for doing that.
So let's just see
how that works.
So here are, basically, the two
important Pthread functions.
There are actually a whole bunch
of them, because they
also provide a bunch of
other facilities.
One is pthread_create, which
creates Pthread.
And one is pthread_join.
So pthread_create basically
is return an identifier.
So when you say create a
Pthread, the Pthread system
says, here's a handle by which
you can name this thread in
the future.
OK.
So it's a very common thing
that the implementer says,
here's the name that you get.
It's called a handle.
So it returns a handle.
It then has an object to set
various thread attributes.
And for most of what we're
going to need, we're just
going to need NULL
for default.
We don't need any special
things like changing the
priority or what have you.
Then what you pass is a void*
pointer to a function, which
is going to be the routine
executed after creation.
So you can name the function
that you want to have it
operate on.
And then you have a single
pointer to an argument that
you're going to pass
to the function.
So when you call something with
Pthreads to create them,
you can't say, and here's
my list of arguments.
If you have more than one
argument, you have to pack it
together into a struct
and pass the
pointer to the struct.
And this function has to be
smart enough to understand how
to unpack it.
We'll see an example
in a minute.
And then, it returns
an error status.
So the most common thing people
do is they don't bother
to check the error status.
OK.
And yet sometimes, you try to
create a Pthread, there's a
reason it can't create one.
And now you keep going thinking
you have one, and
then your program crashes
and you wonder why.
So when you create things,
you should check.
I'm not sure in my code here
whether I checked everywhere.
But you should check.
Do as I say, not as I do.
OK.
So the other key function
is join.
And basically, what you do is
you say, you name the thread
that you want to wait for.
This is the name that
would be returned
by the create function.
And you also give a place where
it can store the status
of the thread when
it terminated.
It's allowed to say, I
terminated normally.
I terminated with a given error
condition or whatever.
But if you don't care
what it is, you
just put in NULL there.
And then it returns
to the error
status of the join function.
So those are the two functions
that you program with.
Question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE]?
PROFESSOR: It's different.
It's different.
So it's basically, if the error
status, if it returns
NULL, it just means everything
went OK.
The handle is you pass a name,
and basically this is *thread.
It stuffs the name into
whatever you give it.
OK so you're not saying,
here's the name.
This is returned as an
output parameter.
So you're giving it an address
of some place to put the name.
OK.
Let's see an example.
So here's Fibonacci
with Pthreads.
So let's just go through that.
So the first part
is pretty good.
This is your original code
that does Fibonacci.
And now what we do is
we have a structure
for the thread arguments.
And so we're going to have an
input argument and an output
argument in this example.
Because Fib takes an input
argument in and
returns Fib of n.
So we're going to call those
input and output.
And we'll call them
thread_args.
And now, here is my void*
function, thread_func, which
takes a pointer.
And what it does is
when it executes--
so what you're going to be able
to do is, as we'll see in
a minute--.
Let me just go through this.
This is going to be the function
called when the
thread is created.
So when the thread is created,
you're just going
to call this function.
And what it's going to get is
the argument that was passed,
which is this *star thing.
And what it does in this case
is it's basically going to
cast the pointer to a thread_arg
struct and
dereference the input, and stick
that into I. Then going
to compute Fib of I. And then
it's going to take, once
again, deference the pointer as
if it's a thread_arg, and
store into the output field
the result of the Fib.
And then it returns NULL.
So that's basically the function
that's going to be
called when the thread
is created.
So in your main routine now,
what happens is we initialize
a bunch of things.
And now, if argc is less
than 2, we'll return 1.
That's fine.
Then we're going to get the
reading that we fail.
That's actually the reading
of the input.
So then, what we do here is we
get n from the command line.
And then if n is less than
30, we're just going to
compute Fib of n.
This is what I evaluated on my
laptop was a good number.
So the idea is there's no point
in creating the extra
thread to do the work if it's
going to be more expensive
than me just doing
the work myself.
So I looked at the overhead of
thread creation and discovered
that if it was smaller than 30,
it's going to be slower to
create another thread
to help me out.
It's sort of like you folks
when you're doing pair
programming, which you're
supposed to be doing, versus
handing it off.
Sometimes, there are some things
that are too small to
ask somebody else to do.
You might as well just do it,
by time you explain what it
is, and so forth.
Same thing here.
What's the point in starting
up a thread to do something
else, because the startup cost
is rather substantial.
So if it's less than 30, well,
we'll just be done.
Otherwise, what we do
is we marshall the
argument to the thread.
We basically set args.input
to n minus 1.
Because args is going to be
what I'm going to pass in.
So I say the input number
is n minus 1.
And now what I do is I create
the thread by saying, give me
the name of the thread
that I'm creating.
This was the field that I said
you could put to be NULL,
which basically lets
you set some policy
parameters and so forth.
I say, execute the
thread_func.
This guy here.
And here's the argument list
that I want to provide it,
which is this args thing.
Once you do the thread_create,
and this is where you depart
from normal C or
C++ semantics.
And in fact, we're going to be
doing more moving in the
direction of C++.
We'll have some tutorials
on that.
What happens is we
check the status.
OK, I actually did check the
status to see whether or not
it created it properly.
But basically now, what's
happening is after I execute
this, it goes off and all the
magic in Pthreads starts
another thread doing
that computation.
And control returns to the
statement after the
pthread_create.
So when the pthread_create
returns, that doesn't mean
it's done computing the thing
you told it to do.
Then, what would be the point?
It returns after it's set up
to operate in parallel the
other thread.
People follow that?
So now at this point, there
are two threads operating.
There's the thread we've
called thread.
And there's whatever the name
of the thread is that we
started on.
So then we, in our own processor
here, we compute Fib
of N minus 2.
And now, what we do is we go
on to join this thread with
the thread that we
had created.
So let's see here.
And the thing that the join does
is if the other thread
isn't done, it sits there and
waits until it is done.
And it does that
synchronization
automatically for you.
And this is the kind of thing a
concurrency platform provides.
It provides the coordination
under the covers for you to be
able to synchronize with it
without you having to
synchronize on your own.
And then, once it does return,
it adds the results together
by taking the result which came
from the Fib of n minus 2
and adds to it the value that
this thread has returned in
the args.output.
And then it prints the result.
So any question about that?
Wouldn't this be fun to write
a really big system in?
People do.
Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE]
PROFESSOR: That's a
tuning parameter.
That's a voodoo parameter.
AUDIENCE: Right.
But in this particular case, it
makes no difference at all.
It would've made a difference
if it was an actual person
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: No, it does
make a difference.
For how fast it computes this?
Absolutely does.
AUDIENCE: That's
not recursive?
PROFESSOR: No, that's right.
This is not recursive.
I'm just doing two things
and then quitting.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] if it's
less than 30, then it's going
to be [INAUDIBLE], right?
PROFESSOR: If it's less than
30, it's fast enough that I
might as well just return.
AUDIENCE: Then why
[INAUDIBLE PHRASE]
to do it.
It would return [INAUDIBLE]
too.
PROFESSOR: No.
But it would be slower.
It would be wasteful
of resources.
Maybe somebody--
AUDIENCE: Well, because you're
using such a bad
algorithm, I guess?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I see.
Oh, OK.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So in any case, that's Pthread's
programming.
There are a bunch of issues.
One is that the overhead of
creating a thread is more than
10,000 cycles.
So it leaves you to only be able
to do very coarse grain
concurrency.
There are some tricks
around that.
One is to use what's called
thread pools.
What I do is I start up, and I
create a bunch of threads.
And I have their names.
I put them in a link list.
And whenever I need to create
one, rather than actually
creating one, I take one out of
the list, much as I would
do memory allocation.
Which you folks are
familiar with.
OK.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
[MANIACAL LAUGHTER]
So basically, you can have
a free list of threads.
And when you need a thread,
you grab the thread.
The second thing
is scalability.
So this code gets about a 1.5
speed up for two cores.
If I want to use three cores
or four cores, what
do I have to do?
Rewrite the whole program.
This program only works
for two cores.
It will also work
for one core.
but basically, it doesn't
really exploit
three or four cores.
It's really bad for
modulatary.
The Fibonacci logic is no longer
neatly encapsulated in
the Fib function.
So where do we see if we
go back to this code?
Here's the Fib function.
Oh, but now, I've
kind of got--
well, this is sort of just
marshaling and calling.
But over here, oh my goodness,
I've got some arguments here.
If n is less than 30,
I give a result.
Otherwise, I'm adding
together--
but wait a minute.
I already specified
Fib up here.
So I'm specifying my serial
implementation, and I'm
specifying a parallel
way of doing it.
And so that's not modular.
If I decided I wanted to change
the Fib, I've got to
change things in two places.
If Fib were something I did.
Code simplicity.
The programmers for this are
actually marshalling arguments.
This is what I call
shades of 1958.
What happened in 1958 that's
relevant to computer science?
What was the big innovation
in 1958?
Programming language.
Fortran.
So, Fortran.
Before Fortran, people wrote
in assembly language.
If you wanted to put three
arguments to a function, you
did a push, push, push, or
passed them in parameters.
Actually, their machines were
so much more primitive than
that it was even more
complicated than you could
imagine, given how complicated
it is today what the
compilers are doing.
But you had marshal the
arguments yourself.
What Fortran did was say,
no, you can actually
write f of a, b, c.
Close paren.
And that it will cause a, b,
and c all to be marshalled
automatically for you.
Well, Pthreads doesn't have that
automatic marshalling.
You got to marshall by hand if
you're going to use pthreads.
And of course, as you can
imagine, that was error prone.
Because there is
no type safety.
Are you calling things with the
right types and so forth?
And so forth.
And also, one of the things here
is that we've created two
jobs that aren't
the same size.
So there's no way that they
have of load balancing.
So this is why pthreads is sort
of the assembly language
level, so that you can do
anything you want in pthreads.
But you have to program
at this kind of very
protocol-laden level.
Next thing I want
to talk about is
threading building blocks.
This is a technology
developed by Intel.
It's implemented as a C++
library that runs on top of
the native Pthreads, typically,
or WinAPI threads.
So it's basically a layer on
top of the Pthread layer.
In this case, the program
specifies
tasks rather than threads.
And tasks are automatically
load balanced across the
threads using a strategy called
work-stealing, which
we'll talk about a little
bit more later.
And the focus for this
is on performance.
They want to write programs that
actually perform well.
So here's Fibonacci in TBB.
So as you'll see, it's better.
But maybe not ideal for what
you might like to express.
So what we do is we declare the
computer, the computation,
it's going to organized as a
bunch of explicit tasks.
So you say that it's
going to be a task.
And FibTask is going to have an
input parameter, n, and an
output parameters, sum.
And what we're going to do is
when the task is started, it
automatically executes the
execute method of this tasking
object here.
And the execute method now
starts to do something that
looks very much like
Fibonacci.
It says if n is less than
2, sum is equal to n.
That's we had before.
And otherwise.
And now what we're going to do
is recursively create two
child tasks, which we basically
do with this
function, allocate_task, giving
it the fib task a name,
where this is basically a method
for allocating out of a
particular type of the
pool, which is an
allocate child pool.
And then similarly for b, we
recursively do for n minus 2.
And then what it does is
it sets the number of
tasks to wait for.
In this case, it's basically
two children plus 1 for
bookkeeping.
So this ends up always being one
more than the things that
you created as subtasks.
And then what we do is we
say, OK, let's spawn.
So this will only
set up the task.
It doesn't actually
say, do it.
So the spawn command says
actually do this computation
here that I set up.
So it actually does b.
Start task b.
And then itself, it executes a
and waits for all of the other
tasks, namely both a
and b, to finish.
And once it's finished, it adds
the results together to
produce the final output.
So this, notice, has the big
advantage over the previous
implementation that this
is actually recursive.
So in doing Fib, you're not
just getting two tasks.
You're recursively getting each
of those two more, and
two more, and two more, down
to the leaves of the
computation.
And then what TBB does is it
load balances those across the
number of available processors
by creating these tasks.
And then, it automatically does
all the load balancing of
the tasks and so forth.
Questions about that?
Any questions?
I don't expect you to be able
to program a TBB, unless I
gave you a book and said,
program a TBB.
But I'm not going to do that.
This is mainly to give you a
flavor of what's in there.
What the alternatives are.
So TBB provides many
C++ templates that
simplify common patterns.
So rather than having to write
that kind of thing for
everything, for example, if
you have loop parallelism.
If you have n things that you
want to have that operate
parallel, you can do a parallel
four and not actually
see the tasks.
It covers them over and
creates the tasks
automatically, so that you can
just say, for I gets 1 to n,
do this to all I, and do them at
the same time essentially.
And it then balances
those and so forth.
It also has to things like
parallel reduce.
Sometimes what you want to do
across an array is not just do
something for every element
of the array.
You may want to add up all the
elements into a single value.
And so it basically has what's
called a reduction function.
It does parallel reduce
to aggregate.
And it's got various other
things, like pipelining and
filtering for doing what's
called software pipelining,
where you have one subsystem
that basically is going to
process the data and pass
it to the next.
So you're going to process it
and pass it to the next.
And it allows you to set up a
software pipeline of things.
It also collides with some
container classes, such as
hash tables, concurrent hash
tables, that allow you to have
multiple tasks beating
on a hash table.
Inserting and deleting from
the hash table at the same
time and a variety of mutual
exclusion library functions,
including locks and
atomic updates.
So it has a bunch of other
facilities that make it much
easier to use than just using
the raw task interface.
OpenMP.
So OpenMP is a specification
produced by an industry
consortium of which the
principal players--
the original principal player
was Silicon Graphics, which
essentially has become
less important in the
industry, let's say.
Put it that way.
And for the most part, recently,
it's been players
from Intel and Sun, which is now
no longer Sun, except that
it is Sun part of Oracle, and
of IBM, and variety of other
industry players.
There's several compilers
available.
Both open source and
proprietary, including gcc,
has OpenMP built-in.
And also, Visual Studio
These are a set of linguistic
extensions to C and C++ or
Fortran in the form of compiler
practice pragmas.
So who knows what a pragma is?
OK.
Good.
Can you tell us what
a pragma is?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's kind
of like a compiler hint.
It's a way of saying to the
compiler, here's something I
want to tell you about the
code that I'm writing.
And it basically is a hint.
So technically, it's not
supposed to have any semantic
impact, but rather suggest how
something might be implemented
by the compiler.
However, in OpenMP's case, they
actually have a compiler--
it does change the semantics
in certain cases.
It runs on top of native threads
and it supports,
especially, loop parallelism.
And then, in the latest version,
it supports a kind of
task parallelism like
we saw with TBB.
So, in fact, their
task parallelism
is fairly to specify.
So here's the Fib code.
So now, this is not
looking too bad.
We basically inserted
a few lines here.
And otherwise, we actually
have the
original Fibonacci code.
So the sharp pragma says, here's
a compiler directive.
And it says, the OMP
says it is an
OpenMP compiler directive.
The task says, oh, the following
things should be
interpreted as an independent
task.
And now, the sharing of memory
in OpenMP is managed
explicitly, because they're
trying to allow for
programming both of distributed
memory clusters,
as well as shared
memory machines.
And so, you have to explicitly
name the shared variables that
you're using.
And here, we're basically
saying, wait for the two
things that we spawned
off here to complete.
So pretty simple code.
It provides many pragma
directives to express common
patterns, such as a parallel
for parallelization.
It also has reduction.
It also has directives for
scheduling and data sharing.
And it has a whole bunch
of synchronization
constructs and so forth.
So it's another interesting
one to do.
The main downside, I would say,
of OpenMP is that the
performance is not really
very composable.
So if you have a program you've
written with OpenMP
over here, another one here,
and you want to put them
together, they fight
with each other.
You have to have your
concept of what are
going to be the programs.
The task parallelism helps
a bit with that.
But the basic OpenMP is very
much of the model, I know how
many cores I'm running on.
I can set that.
And then I can have it
automatically parse up the
work for those many.
But once you've done that, some
other job, some other
part of the system that wants to
do the same thing, then you
get oversubscription and perhaps
some [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Nevertheless, a very
interesting system.
And very accessible, because
it's in most of the standard
compilers these days.
What we're going to
look at is Cilk++.
So this is actually a small set
of linguistics extensions
to C++ to support fork-join
parallelism.
And it was developed by Cilk
Arts, which is an MIT
spin-off, which was acquired
by Intel last year.
So this is now an Intel
technology.
And the reason I know about it
is because I was the founder
of Cilk Arts.
It was based on 15 years of
research at MIT out of my
research group.
And we won a bunch of awards,
actually, for this work.
In fact, the work-stealing
scheduler that's in it is
provably efficient.
In other words, it's not just
a heuristic scheduler.
It's actually got a mathematical
proof that it's
an effective scheduler.
And in fact, was the inspiration
for things like
the work-stealing in TBB and the
new task mechanisms and so
forth in OpenMP, as well as a
bunch of other people who've
done work-stealing.
It in addition provides a
hyperobject library for
parallelizing code with global
variables, which we'll talk
about later.
And it includes two tools that
you'll come to know and love.
One is the Cilkscreen race
detector, and the other is the
Cilkview scalability analyzer.
Now, what we're going to be
using in this class is going
to be the Cilk++ technology
that was developed at Cilk
Arts and then massaged
a little bit
when it got to Intel.
There is a brand new Intel
technology with Cilk built
into their compiler.
And it is due to come out
in like, two weeks.
So our timing for this was it
would've been nice to have you
folks on the new Intel
Cilk+ technology.
But we're going to go with
this one for now.
It's not going to make too big
a difference to you folks.
But you should just be aware
that coming down the pike,
there's actually some much
more cleanly integrated
technology that you can use
that's in the Intel compiler.
So here's how we do nested
parallelism in Cilk++.
So basically, this
is Fibonacci.
And now, what I have here is,
if you notice, I've got two
keywords, cilk_spawn
and cilk_sync.
And this is how you write
parallel Fibonacci in Cilk.
This is it.
I've inserted two key words,
and my program is parallel.
The cilk_spawn keyword says that
the named child function
can execute in parallel with
the parent caller.
So when you say x equals
cilk_spawn or Fib of n minus
1, it does the same thing
that you normally think.
It calls the child.
But after it calls the child,
rather than waiting for it to
return, it goes on to
the next statement.
So then, the statement y equals
Fib of n minus 2 is
going on at the same time
as the calculation of
Fib of n minus 1.
And then, the cilk_sync says,
don't go past this point until
all the children you've spawned
off have returned.
And since this is a recursive
program, it generates gobs of
parallelism, if it's
a big thing.
So one of the key things about
Cilk++, is unlike Pthreads--
Pthreads, when you say,
pthread_create, it actually
goes and creates a
piece of work.
In Cilk++, these keywords
only grant permission.
They say you may execute these
things in parallel.
It doesn't insist that they
be executed in parallel.
The program may decide, no, in
fact, I'm going to just call
this, and then return, and
then execute this.
So it only grants permission,
and the Cilk++ runtime system
figures out how to load balance
it and schedule it.
Cilk++ also supports
loop parallelism.
So here's an example of an
in-place matrix transpose.
So I want to take this matrix
and flip it on its major axis.
And we can do it
with for loops.
As you know, for loops
are not the best way
to do matrix transpose.
Right?
It's better to do divide
and conquer.
But here's how you
could do it.
And here, I made the indices
run from 0, not 1, because
that's the way you do
it in programming.
But if I did it up here, then
these things get to be n minus
1, n minus 1, and then it gets
too crowded on the slide.
And I said, OK, I'll just put
a comment there rather than
try to sort it out.
So here's what I'm saying, is
this outer loop is parallel.
It's going from 1
to n minus 1.
And saying, do all those
things in parallel.
And each one is going through
a different number of
iterations of j.
So you can see you actually need
some load balancing here,
because some of these are going
through just one step,
and some are going through
n minus 1 steps.
It's basically the amount of
work in every iteration of the
outer loop here is different.
I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: No. i equals 1 is
where you want to start.
Because you don't have
to move the diagonal.
You only have to go across
the top here.
And for each of those, copy it
into the appropriate column.
Flip it into the appropriate
column.
Flip the two things.
Actually, transpose is one
of these functions.
I remember writing my first
transpose functions.
And when I was done, I somehow
had the identity.
Because I basically made the
loops go from 1 to n and 1 to
n and swapped them.
So I swapped them.
So I said, oh, that
was a lot of work
to compute the identity.
No, you've got to make sure
you only go through a
triangular iteration space in
order to make sure you swap--
and then swap.
This is an in-place swap.
So that's cilk_for.
That's basically it.
There are some more facilities
we'll talk about.
But that's basically
it for parallel
programming in Cilk++.
The other part is, how do you
do it so you get fast code?
Which we'll talk about.
Now, Cilk has serial
semantics.
And what that means is unlike
some of the other ones, it's
kind of what OpenMP was
aspiring to do.
The idea is that if I, for
example here, delete these two
keywords, I get a C++ code.
And that code is always a legal
way to execute this
parallel code.
So the parallel code may have
more behaviors of its
nondeterministic code.
But always, it's legal to
treat it as if it's just
straight C++.
And the reason for that is
that, really, we're only
granting permission for
parallel execution.
So even though I put in these
keywords, I still can execute
it serially if I wish.
They don't command parallel
execution.
To obtain this serialization,
you can do it by hand by just
defining a cilk_for to be for,
and the cilk_spawn and
cilk_sync to be empty.
Or there's a switch to the
Cilk++ composite that does
that for you automatically.
And it's probably the preferred
way of doing it.
But the idea is conceptually,
you can sprinkle in these
keywords, and if you don't
want it anymore, fine.
If you want to compile it with
the straight c compilers, it's
better to use the Cilk++
compiler to do it.
But if you wanted to ship it
off to somebody else, you
could just do these sharp
defines, and they could
compile it with their compilers,
and it would be the
same as a serial C++ code.
So the Cilk++ concurrency
platform allows the program to
express potential parallelism
in application.
So it says, where is
the parallelism?
It doesn't say how
to schedule it.
It says, where is it?
And then, it gets mapped onto,
at runtime, dynamically mapped
onto the processor cores.
And the way that it does the
mapping is mathematically
provably a good way
of doing it.
And if you take one of my
graduate courses, I can teach
you how that works.
We'll do a little bit of study
of simple scheduling.
But the actual schedule it
uses is more involved.
But we'll cover it
a little bit.
Here's the components
of the Cilk++
platform on a single slide.
So let me just say
what they are.
The first one is the keywords.
So you get to put
things in there.
And if you elide or create the
serialization, then you get
the C++ code or C code, for
which then you can run your
regression test and demonstrate
you have some good
single-threaded program.
Alternatively, you can send it
through the Cilk++ compiler,
which is based on a conventional
compiler.
In our case, it will be GCC.
You can link that with the
hyperobject library, which
we'll talk about when we start
talking about synchronization.
It produces a binary.
If you run that binary on the
runtime system, you can also
run it to the regression test.
And in particular, if you run
it on the runtime system,
running on one core, it should
behave identically to having
run it through this path with
just the serial code.
And of course, you get
exceptional performance.
These, I think, were originally
marketing slides.
However, there's also the fact
that you may get what are
called races in your code, which
are bugs that will come
up that won't occur in your
serial code, but will occur in
your parallel code.
Cilk has a race detector to
detect those, for which you
can run parallel regression
tests to produce your reliable
multi-threaded code.
And then, the final piece of
it is there's this thing
called Cilkview, which allows
you to analyze the scalability
of your software.
So you can run, in fact, on a
single core or on a small
number of cores.
And then, you can predict how
it's going to behave on a
large number of cores.
So let's just, to conclude
here, talk about races.
Because they're the nasty,
nasty, nasty thing we get into
parallel programming.
And then next time, we'll
get deeper into the Cilk
technology itself.
So the most basic kind of race
there is what's called a
determinacy race.
Because if you have one of these
things, your program
becomes nondeterministic.
It doesn't do the same
thing every time.
A determinacy race occurs when
two logically parallel
instructions access the same
memory location, and at least
one of the instructions performs
a write, performs a
store, to that location.
So here's an example.
I have a cilk_for here, both
branches of which are
incrementing x.
This is basically going.
The index is going.
i equals 0 and i equals 1.
And then, it's asserting
that x equals 2.
If I run this serially,
the assertion passes.
But when I run it in parallel,
it may not produce a 2.
It can produce a 1.
And let's see why that is.
So the way to understand this
code is to think about its
execution in terms of a
dependency [? dag ?].
So here I have my initialization
of x.
Then once that's done, the
cilk_for loop allows me to do
two things at a time, b and c,
which are both incrementing x.
And then, I assert that
x equals 2 when
they're both done.
Because that's the semantics
of the cilk_for.
So let's see where
the race occurs.
So remember that it occurs
when I have two logically
parallel instructions
that access
the same memory location.
Here, it's going to
be the location x.
And at least one of them
performs a write execution.
So if we actually looked closer,
I want to expand this
into this larger thing.
Because as you know, X++ is not
done on a memory location.
It's not done as a single
instruction.
It's done as a load,
x into a register.
Increment the register, and then
store the value back in.
And meanwhile, there's another
register on another processor,
presumably, that's doing
the same thing.
So this is the one I
want to look at.
This is just a zooming in, if
you will, on this dependency
graph to look a little bit finer
grain at what's actually
happening one step at a time.
So the determinacy race,
recall, occurs--
this is by something,
I'm going to say
again, you should memorize.
So you should know
what this is.
You should be able to say what
a determinacy race is.
It's when you have two
instructions that are both
accessing the same location,
and one of
them performs write.
And here, I have that.
This guy is in parallel.
He's being stored to here.
This is also a race.
He's been reading it, and
this guy is writing it.
So let's see what can happen
and what can go wrong here.
So here's my value,
x, in memory.
And here's my two registers on,
presumably, two different
processors.
So one thing is that
you can typically--
and this is not quite the case
with real hardware-- but an
abstraction of the hardware
is that you can treat the
parallel execution from a
logical point of view as if
you're interleaving instructions
from the
different processors.
OK.
We're going to talk in three or
four lectures about where
that isn't the right
abstraction.
But it is close to the
right abstraction.
So here, basically, we execute
statement one, which causes x
to become 0.
Now let's execute
statement two.
That causes r1 to become 0.
Then, I can increment that.
It becomes a 1.
All well and good.
But now if the next logical
thing that happens is that r2
is set to the value x,
then it becomes 0.
Then we increment it.
And now, he stores
back 1 into x.
And now, this guy stores
1 back into x.
And notice that now,
we [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
go to the assertion.
And we assert that it's
2, and it's not the 2.
It's a 1.
Because we lost one
of the updates.
Now the reason race bugs are
really pernicious is, notice
that if I had executed this
whole branch, and then this
whole branch, I get
the right answer.
Or if I executed this whole
branch, and then this whole
branch, I get the
right answer.
The only time I don't get the
right answer is when those two
things happen to interleave
just so.
And that's what happens with
race conditions generally, is
that you can run your code a
million times and not see the
bug, and then run it once, and
it crashes out in the field.
Or what's happened is there
have been race bugs
responsible for failure of
space shuttle to launch.
You have the North American
blackout of 2001?
2003?
It wasn't that long ago.
It was like, 10 years ago.
We had big black out caused by
a race condition in the code
run by the power companies.
There been medical instruments
that have fried people, killed
them and maimed them, because
of race conditions.
These are really serious bugs.
Question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] when you
said, the only time that that
code is actually execute
serially?
PROFESSOR: It could execute in
parallel if it happened that
these guys executed
before these guys.
If you think of a larger
context, a whole bunch of
these things, and I have two
routines where they're both
incrementing x in the middle
of great big parallel
programs, it could be that
they're executing perfectly
well in parallel.
But if those two small sections
of code happen to
execute like this or like this,
then you're going to end
up with it executing
correctly.
But if they execute sort of at
the same time, it would not
necessarily behave correctly.
So there are two types of races
that people talk about,
a read race and a write race.
So suppose you have two
instructions that access a
location, x.
And suppose that a
is parallel to b.
Both a and b are both reads,
you get no race.
That's good.
Because there's no way.
But if one is a read and one is
a write, then one of them
is going to see a different
value, depending upon whether
it occurred before and
after the write.
Or if they both are writing,
one can lose a value.
So these are read races.
And this is a write race.
So we say that the two
sections of code are
independent if they have
no determinacy
races between them.
So for example, this piece of
code is incrementing y, and
this is incrementing x.
And y is not equal to x.
Those are independent
pieces of code.
So to avoid races, you want to
make sure that the iterations
of your cilk_for are
independent.
So what's going on in one
iteration is different from
what's going on in another.
That you're not writing
something in one that you're
using in the next,
for example.
Between a cilk_spawn and the
corresponding cilk_sync, the
code of the spawn child should
be independent of the code of
the parent.
OK?
Including any code executed
by additional
spawned or called children.
So it's basically saying, when
you spawn something off, don't
then go and do something that's
going to modify the
same locations.
You really want to modify
different locations.
It's fine if they both read
the same locations.
But it's not fine for one
of them to read and
one of them to write.
One thing here to understand
is that when you spawn a
function, the arguments are
actually executed serially
before the actual
spawn occurs.
So you evaluate the arguments,
and you set it all up, then
you spawn the function.
So the actual spawn
occurs after the
evaluation of arguments.
So they're evaluated
in the parent.
Machine word size matters.
So this is generally
the case for races.
By the way, races are
not just Cilk stuff.
These races occur in all of
these concurrency platforms.
I'm illustrating Cilk because
that's what we're going to be
using in our labs
and so forth.
So it turns out machine
word size matters.
And you can have races in
packed data structures.
So for example, on some
machines, if you declare a
char a and char b in a struct,
then updating x and x, b in
parallel may cause a race,
because they're both actually
operating on a word basis.
Now on the Intel architectures,
that doesn't happen.
Because Intel supports atomic
updates of single bytes.
So you don't have to
worry about it.
But if you were accessing bits
within a word, you could end
up with the same thing.
You access bit five and bit
three, you think you're acting
independently, but in fact,
you're reading the whole word
or the whole byte in
order to access it.
The technology that you're going
to be using fortunately
comes with a race detector,
which you will find invaluable
for debugging your stuff.
And so this is kind of like
a Valgrind for races.
What's good about this race
detector is it provides a rock
hard guarantee.
If you have a deterministic
program that on a given input
could possibly behave any
differently from your serial
program, from the corresponding
serial program,
if you got rid of the parallel
keywords, this tool,
Cilkscreen, guarantees to
report and localize the
offending race.
It'll tell you, you got
a race between this
location and that location.
And it's up to you to find
it and fix it, but it
can tell you that.
It employs regression test
methodology, where the
programmer provides
test inputs.
So if you don't provide test
inputs to elicit the race, you
still can have a bug.
But if you have a test input
that in any way could behave
differently than the serial
execution, bingo.
It'll tell you.
It identifies a bunch of things
involving the race,
including a stack trace.
It runs off the binary
executable using what's called
dynamic instrumentation.
So that's kind of like Valgrind,
except it actually
does this as it's running.
It uses a technology called PIN,
which you can read about.
P-I-N, which is a nice platform
for doing code
rewriting and analysis
on the fly.
It runs about 20 times slower
than real time.
So you basically use
it for debugging.
So the first part of project
four is basically coming up to
speed with this technology.
And so, there's some
good things.
And that's going to be
available tomorrow.
Is that what we said?
Yeah, that will be available
tomorrow.
So this is actually--
this is tons of fun.
Most people in most places
don't get to play with
parallel technology like this.